you did this
by the way you did this oh no i like
this
doesn't make me angry though i i enjoy
dilly because he's just so
completely like delusional you know i
got we got a message
from somebody on one of our old dilly
clips
uh saying like you know dooley you when
he goes live on the scope
he actually has like 20 000 people
watching him you're picking on the wrong
guy
the wrong guy the wrong guy let's check
out let's check out what 26
000 boomers watch
sorry guys that's not i really apologize
i didn't know that was coming i
apologize
i would have warned you jesus that was
rough
invite your family definitely invite
your
liberal co-workers you know what's weird
is uh doing this old school look at the
mic
i had to put the normal microwave dilly
doing his [ __ ]
outside that's not old school
old school would imply that it was ever
good to do a broadcast show
on [ __ ] apple headphones you know
what i mean like nobody would that's not
old school
it's pretty kick-ass no it's not it
always sounds terrible
it's not retro yeah today's broadcast
we're doing a little bit uh old school
unorthodox doing it outdoors today
i couldn't miss today though it's too
big of a day we got trump 2020 launching
with
mike pence your boy trump and pence
2020 right and i'm gonna find a way to
uh to do the show no matter what i think
that would make this video awesome is if
a helicopter landed and it was both
trump and pence
and they just said please stop it just
stop that was the emergency turnaround
it wasn't all right it was the emergency
turnaround they're having a meeting
about i get
[ __ ] dilly to stop just stop talking
it's too big of a day we got so much
happening today
dilly is a bigger threat to trump's
presidency than google
he really is that's all that's all
google needs to do is give dilly a
million subs
and that's it it's over let them run
wild yeah
and that's the thing too you like you
morons don't realize that you are
actually hurting yourselves because you
keep you keep actually de-platforming a
lot of cringe
right-wingers and it's actually helping
too like there's no evidence of
there's much less evidence of nazi
larping because you keep deleting all of
it
you're actually helping trump dilly
looks like a guy that should be in a wwe
original movie
you know what i mean like the marine six
yeah like he would be like uh neil
mcdonald's [ __ ] sidekick
exactly yeah he wouldn't be the main guy
obviously but he's a sidekick guy
especially dilly's the guy you look at
and go find him
and then they go all right i got him
yeah he's dead right yeah
helicopter blades cut him up uh
i mean between the border the middle
east
still waiting no biting talking about
revolution
that's a good job that sounds just like
joe biden really
identical don't blame talking revolution
we got joe biden out here with the
revolution talk
and oops
there we go and as if that weren't
enough
we also have the dao going insane
through the roof because potus tweeting
out about a chinese
potential chinese deal
i will be skipping ahead please do wants
nothing to do with trump
absolutely assures her ex-husband
there's no way i'm voting for anyone
else
they're all doing it too all of them the
democrats entire platform is we're going
to raise your taxes
for free health care and free college or
whatever
wow that's crazy the democrats are
running on more taxes that's crazy dilly
this is such a crazy development of
things the same
talking points dilly you're winning dude
are you so happy
do you know how many leather bracelets i
ordered that say 45
on them i'm a good businessman i
wouldn't have ordered all those
bracelets
if i didn't think trump was gonna win
dilly drops
or why would democrats run joe biden
because joe biden is the last
hope for the chinese that's why joe
biden's running
if you want to know why china is going
to cut a deal is this a dilly drop
a dylan is this a dilly drop dilly
joe biden is not the last chance for the
chinese
bitcoin is the last chance for the
chinese and they will bleed us dry
every [ __ ] night until we're all poor
it has nothing to do with joe biden with
trump
it's because they're they're running and
backing joe biden but they're listening
to joe biden speak
i guarantee you this is the leverage
that trump is using
trump's like oh you guys are gonna wait
for joe biden okay all right and then
joey goes out there and he's like
hey who wants to wait who wants to pay
more money in texas
what's this voice this is a new thing
we've watched a lot of dilly
this is a new thing he's incorporating
what is this voice
he's like doing he's being funny man
yeah yeah dude you gotta like make fun
of these libtards
bro so lisa goes oh my god please put
the
club techno music back on i'd rather
listen to that you guys entertaining
oh you guys want to pay more taxes
chinese now amy is a friend
oh [ __ ] where is everybody going where
you guys
going come back it's actually just dilly
talking to his audience
oh yeah exactly
you guys realize joe biden's been doing
his stump speeches from like a line
out of dunkin donuts right okay well
you're selling stroke spoons from a
balcony and a [ __ ]
horrible double tray 80 a night double
tree
in i'm going to assume aurora colorado
based on the background
so great
everyone's killing it i guess an aurora
colorado reference
that was just a joke for filipinos
[Laughter]
go is in the same position that hillary
was which is how do you survive this
right we've discussed this before i mean
the deep state is aging out you guys
know that right
a lot of these deep state actors are
just [ __ ] dying off man
you're right because you think there's a
cabal that's inside our government
and now it's it's first off if you
believe that then there's been a
kabbalah in the government since the
beginning of the government yeah you
don't think they were interested in new
people
exactly thank you just like the fbi or
the cia right
like if if the fbi stopped taking people
in during around the j
edgar hoover days there'd be no fbi now
they'd all just be dead
right so there's always like a hey you
know and hey
stupid by the way i do believe that the
deep state which by the way people like
you have ruined
oh yeah the concept of and now people
make fun of it but there is a deep state
there is ap
there is a as the trump investigation
with peter strzok and [ __ ] has proven
there is a
we're all we're looking out for each
other it's not like our yeah
in a room with a wrap no there's not a
meeting in a volcano like mr burns
people meeting on a
holographic yeah no yeah no but you know
there are guys that are like
yes so we're going to um prove that
trump
was working with the russians right and
the other agents like
yeah okay we gotta we're gonna prove
that trump conspired with the russians
but like
the deep state is uh
this is how the deep state works it's oh
hey here's an fbi
fbi special agent royce right uh
good guy wants to do the best for the
country does his job right
then we find out that the old royce he's
got a little bit of a gambling problem
so we get him in deep with some bookies
and then you bail him out it's
like they use mafia tactics to this day
or maybe maybe royce likes to
maybe royce likes to [ __ ] hookers and
just like that guy in house of cards
maybe one of the hookers he [ __ ]
happens to be maybe
under 18. and now we got him and then
they just show you a folder
and then they're like trump conspired
with russia yeah and then or you [ __ ]
a 17 year old problem you pick
you pick so which one is it and then
they go
dude trump yeah orange man am i right
terrible
that's how it works philly you think
they're just old you think they're all
just sitting around right now you think
george soros is sitting around
you know george soros has a kid right
stupid yeah
like what is he talking about soros's
kid is now like
the big swinging yep i hate deli
democrats would immediately start
screaming for partisan issues and
right now i think that i think
christopher wray still
carries favor with the democrats which
is a good thing
all of his talking points are just
whatever
the morning conservative show was
talking about you know what i mean
that's really all it is and then he adds
some lies about things
yes all of his talking points are like
what did rush limbaugh say today
yeah and when like somebody like mark
levin does like a show and he goes
look these people are going to have to
start looking at other options
joe biden's not going to beat president
trump
then dilly goes so far as to go i have
inside information that the democrats
are panicking right now
that's all he does he takes your talking
point but adds the lie of
no no but i know person